[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us for
many families the cost of a professional
holiday photo is out of reach but in
Lynchburg Virginia Janet shamlian found
one woman and a team of volunteers at
the Christmas studio giving families
what can only be described as a
priceless gift it was an offer
almost too good to be true but when the
doors opened they discovered it was real
a photo session in a festive setting
with a team of pros behind the lens for
delicious dickerson and her sons and
every family that comes to the Christmas
studio in Lynchburg the offer of a
holiday photo came without a price tag
have you ever had that done before no we
don't normally do them professionally 12
year old Brianna Lane came with her mom
and sister Kaylee I dreamed of doing
this but it's never really happened and
now my dream is came true brandy Lane is
a caretaker who seldom has had the
chance to be cared for if you had to pay
out of pocket for this I would never be
able to do it
living on a limited budget would never
ever ever be able to do it before today
brandy had only selfies of her family
you guys took it mama hug - photographer
Leah Stoffer dreamed up the idea I've
come across a lot of families throughout
the years that asked her like hey can I
have that photo that's only good family
professional photo that we have and I
just started thinking about those
families so she put out a call for help
everyone she asked said yes and then she
let the community know when I started
doing this I was worried that no
families would show up and someone told
me
Leah's one family shows up that's all
she needn't of worry they hope for 40
families 87 signed up each one got the
star treatment including hair and makeup
and a holiday photo for brandy Lane and
her girls just what they needed we're
just kind of starting over but we're
getting there this is a good start a
moment captured forever and a gift for
CH there is no price waiting for our
Christmas tree around here all three of
us all three of us all three of us have
asked shows how much cut we have there
there's still those two chairs there's
two chairs will you show the two sad
little chairs where we think a good good
Christmas all right before we know a
Christmas tree